[Musik]
das jodel eine tradition aus den alten
doch ist es deshalb altmodisch das sieht
hier niemand so beim rosenfest in konten
in der schweiz
in workshops kommen anfänger und
fortgeschrittene zusammen darunter auch
einige jüngere teilnehmer weil es cool
ist es ist zeitlos also wenn etwas
richtig gut ist dann ist das nicht ans
alter gebunden finde ich ich glaube wenn
man freude hat an der stimme dann kommt
es nicht darauf an ob es für die alten
oder die jungen gemacht ist ich glaube
musik ist für alle gemacht
gerade erlebte alpine gesang ein
comeback zb in modernen interpretationen
beim eurovision song contests 2017
schafft es dieser mix aus jodeln rap und
pop aus rumänien immerhin auf den
siebten platz
[Musik]
ein viraler hitmaschine des schweizer dj
antoine in der jude version als werbung
für den kanton wallis
[Musik]
jodeln kann man heute auch mit einer app
erlernen oder sogar an der universität
seit knapp einem jahr kann man an der
hochschule luzern jodeln studieren im
studiengang volksmusik doch jodeln ist
gar nicht so einfach typisch sind die
schnellen wechsel zwischen tiefer brust
und hoher kopfstimme
[Musik]
auch beim dudler der wiener form des
jodelns
das besondere hier der dudler ist keine
reine vokalmusik sondern wird von
instrumenten begleitet juden ist vor
allem auch ein gemeinschaftserlebnis
[Musik]
gibt es auch unheimliche energie also
ich merke dass immer wenn wir wenn wir
wirklich sehr viertelfestival sind man
kann fast nicht einschlafen weil man so
energie ziert ist das jodeln soll als
kommunikationsform in den bergen
entstanden sein
ich rufe von einer alm zur anderen heute
wird er zum spaß gejodelt so wird die
tradition in die gegenwart geholt zb
über improvisation
kann man doch reden und dann bringt hier
[Musik]
der musiker markus privat organisiert
das jubelfest und beobachtet dass immer
mehr menschen das jodeln für sich
entdecken
[Musik]
die leute suchen vielleicht auch wieder
was eigenes konzert im kurs nehmen so
wie ich will sagen meine wurzeln
aber jeder hat seine eigene geschichte
wir dazu kommt manche über die stimme
manche über die eigene musikalische
geschichte und dann denken sie heute im
norden weil es keine sprache hat keine
wortbedeutung in diesem sinne weil es
auch eine herausforderung darstellt weil
auch das klischee ein anreiz darstellt
[Musik]
jodeln ist also längst mehr als der
einst so belächelte alpen gesang auch
außerhalb der berge im nächsten jahr
zieht das rudel fest zum ersten mal in
die großstadt nach berlin